hachimachi that middle class famous tour
is in full swing gipperino you ain't
lying fatty it's a live comedy show we
play a little ayg with the crowd great
way to introduce people to the show
bring the squad come out and see us
we're coming baby yeah gang these
tickets are selling quickly uh so make
sure you get your tickets we're coming
in we're going to be red bank new jersey
then we're going to seattle portland all
in august then in september we're going
kansas city springfield st louis then
we're going down to nashville hitting
indy coming home to philly baby the
chicken's got to come home to roost then
we're hitting providence rhode island up
there to bean town get those tickets
let's go welcome to another exciting
edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is r u garbage take two little show we
sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find that they grow up to be
classy yeah they're just a big old piece
of [__] trash i'm your host dave foley
coming at you on a beautiful day we're
down here in aunt toddy's basement the
recession is hitting the household very
hard oh no she just tried to sell me
back to our vacuum cleaner
for the listener i just didn't take two
i did the same joke
still got him
my co-host is coming at you from across
the table it's a family episode this is
a serious broadcast god damn it quit
screwing around stop flubbing lines
this guy stinks i'll take 98 of the
intro
who's doing these cute cards what's
going on
my co-host is coming at you from across
the table as i said it's a family
episode he's the ceo of are you garbage
he's international businessman he is the
prince of park avenue the king of the
boards yeah [__] mr neptune 2005.
give it up for kj kevin james right is
that the new one you told me you were
gonna drop because i got one just wait
for it and it's mr
neptune what are you talking am i
pharrell come on what's up everybody
thanks for tuning in as always please
make sure you rate me if you subscribe
on itunes over there full video
available on youtube as you know those
numbers are
up t-ball from the rafters okay and then
obviously
i mean
the [__] army of garbage shout out to
www.patreon.com garbage the greatest
goddamn website in all this here land
shout out to sam yam and jack conte the
founders of that [__] greatest
website over there oh yeah uh also
people back right there little bobble
heads with the boys beautiful piece of
artwork right sign up you get bonus
episodes of ayg and then you get to fan
favorite
hard feelings which is a completely
different podcast
than ayg some would say better
i would say that i got a list today
uh it's behind the scenes it's mean to
big man we really go at it it's a lot of
fun it's uh you know behind behind the
curtain a little bit yeah a little hr a
little clean clean out the bad blood
yeah
the only way we know how to do it
dysfunctional that's where we like to
live and having a nice quick shout out
to our producer shortener the magic man
makes us all look good works the ones
and twos he crosses the tees he dots the
eyes give it up for tebow mcmuffin mr
toby mcmullen what's up dudes what up
t-boned all right if anybody want to see
the outtakes i'm fully blown on the
intro you can venmo me at toby mcmahon
thanks and another thing mr neptune
sounds like a professional bowler
shout out to the tune no mr neptune
would be the person like the mermaid
dancer the like the the mermaid of the
boardwalk what the mermaid of the boy
that's not a thing like yeah like yeah
they do like short towns they have like
the mermaid award
for like it's like a pageant mr neptune
would be like the guy with the trident
that comes out of the water like aquaman
all right that's to show you that's an
award i won mr neptune you were named mr
neptune down there you're mr idiot let's
continue
uh yeah i mean what is it like maybe in
the 1920s they did that step right up
step right in that's what i was getting
at okay jesus i'm sorry i'm sorry your
bit stunk all right let's do it one more
time
one more time take 48.
we were talking about this slightly what
were we talking about i got something i
want to say too okay uh we were talking
about this slightly on the uh on the
aeroplane that we were just on together
um
picking up your check from work how did
you used to to to pull that move what
did you do i assumed you were a friday
guy the second they were ready because
that's how i like to roll well most of
high school i worked at a grocery store
shout out to acme the acame it was a
bagger local 1144 i believe and i forget
what the local was i was in the union
though had to pay my dues all right
relax you weren't putting up any [__]
hotels in vegas i was blowing up taxis
kippy buffalino over here
the hard-working union man all right at
13. like rosie the riveter um
for the bonnet and everything big set of
cans on me
uh yeah i worked at a grocery store
so friday after i think that would have
been ready thursday i forget what it was
whatever i love the thursday ready
whatever day they were ready we would go
scoop them if you weren't working you'd
go scoop them and then they cashed them
right there because i don't know
supermarkets used to do that cash
payroll
and they would charge you a little bit
but not if you work there like you like
if you went in as a non-employee they
would cash it like up to whatever two
thousand dollars
and take whatever you know they wet
their beaks charge you a cucumber but we
wouldn't uh they wouldn't charge us so
i'd walk i'd walk with cash right away
that's nice
dangerous and i would say and then i
would buy a pack of bernies right there
too shout out to marlboro marlboro miles
i was smoking back then
high school ah i love the thursday ready
they're ready on thursday
but they don't you're not allowed to
come get them till friday but if you
work that shift thursday you might be
able to leave with it they'd let you
take it home hey tomorrow's my day off
you care if i grab it yeah
tomorrow oh those [__] weren't there
man i had to come with my day off
[__] feel like a loser checks ready
yeah then you gotta [__] hang up by
the bar well they're not quite ready yet
they used to love [__] stringing you
along yeah but if the smart kids
would go get it on monday
why to not [__] blow it for the
weekend yeah but then what am i gonna
not party on the weekend i gotta have my
[__] i gotta have my miller high
lives
my [__] [__] i'm gonna sit there
like a judge no [__]
but those kids that [__] had had good
head on their shoulders they'd wait till
much i've been poor my whole enti i mean
i've i've been living you know some
would argue my bank account would argue
that i'm still living paycheck to
paycheck at the moment
uh
but
yeah i never i never had money ever i
don't know if you want me to cut this or
not but the reason we started talking
about it because you said we might
switch over to paychecks
yeah
yeah yeah yeah me and t-bone waiting
here at [__] no i don't like that
no no no no no no t-bone wanted but
checks or crackheads i want direct
deposit like a gentleman sure yeah it
would be direct deposit i'm not going to
print you out of check ah come on that
would be fun no no no no no no no put a
little mailbox for tax purposes
this is hard feelings grab my check
phil x they're screwing me
also on the patreon i didn't know phil
phil phil x sent me a picture of it uh
when we called him to see if we could
afford the to sponsor the race our
financial advisor phil x he put new guy
luke put a picture of phil x like on the
phone like in the corner is really
[__] good new guy luke does good
stuff he's all right he's a good kid i
uh i wanted to bring this up
uh it's been very well documented about
how i manage uh the eggs in my apartment
yeah right
i crack an a if i'm making some
scrambies in the morning which i tend to
you crack it and put it back in the
thing and i made a video the other day a
lot of hate a lot of hate sure you know
he would have thought i was [__]
which we're together with a baby in the
grand canyon or something we're together
on this i always thought that you didn't
like it that the missus did it and you
thought it was crazy no i do it she's
not the biggest fan but so that's that's
what brings us to this okay so i made
that video i got trash pretty hard
and she was like yeah whatever for the
record it's cracking an egg cracking an
egg keep the dozen of eggs on the
counter where you're making bread and
you put the shells in i put the shell
back in close it up put it in the fridge
and when the 12 is gone the end of the
weekend
sometimes it's like a day and a half if
i'm having breakfast for dinner
i'm doing keita
[__] 90 eggs 90 eggs a week i'm on yo
rock take it easy
okay all right then then you throw it
out i do the same thing it limits
cross-contamination
that's what i say the sound yeah the the
yolk gets everywhere if you're it gets
all over the [__] it's everywhere and if
you don't have a garbage this started
when i moved out on my own in college
for the first time it didn't have a
garbage disposal like the garbage
disposal you just [__] chuck them in
there oh really yeah
i didn't know that what do you do with
them do you have a garbage disposal
never you still don't like in your your
family your mom's not patty doesn't have
a garbage are you nuts
no that thing has power down there how
do you guys do it have you got a
professor on a [__] stationary bike
yeah no no garbage disposal i didn't
wait a garbage disposal for suckers yeah
please show me this one because that's
more piping it always breaks and always
something always goes right it's been in
my house for 35 years there's never been
anything no you drop your wedding ring
down there yeah that's my kind of videos
you get stuck when your aunt comes over
um now she gets stuck
would you get stuck in the garbage
disposal is it always the girl that gets
stuck
yeah what's the guy going to do if he's
stuck he's hemmed up hey get back here
what the [__]
please
hey it's cindy don't go nowhere
well i'm gonna run and call the plumber
oh you could just suck my dick real
quick
what the hell kind of video are you
watching i didn't know it was always the
girl that got stuck
yeah all right
i don't know you could crack eggs in
there either way can you put cans and
[__] in there too
it's not an incinerator
egg shells are pretty hard put your dead
pets down there
egg shells aren't hard you idiot that's
crazy they're like the most delicate
thing in the world no but they're jagged
that's like glass they come padded man
that's like glass though what that's
nuts you could put eggshell ah man i
always wanted one of those yeah i
thought they were for suckers and his ex
response was because it's more pipes
yeah you're not living like a poor
person
um so that's when i started when i
didn't have a garbage disposal because
then you throw them out and in my
younger days you would throw them out
and that trash wouldn't always make it
out right away like in college there'd
be like two or three bags stuck up
there's eggs falling you ever have a bad
egg you ever crack open an egg and it
just smells like sulfur i don't think so
i'm real weird with my eggs i keep them
tight too i did that once i don't know
what happened if they got left out or
something like that
it's like someone threw a [__] stink
bomb in the kitchen but my [__] i wish i
took a picture of it this morning while
i while we were gone while we were out
there in la la land
my wife went and bought
a hole and it like a ceramic egg holder
so i can't do that no more oh that sucks
you take them out of the
i know you're talking about put them in
this like knife which i don't like
because it's classy no very classical
but you don't know how long they've been
there that's the only thing dude eggs do
not last in my apartment also i heard
this thing you can feed them to the dog
it's like a really good sense
uh thing of protein t-bone can i get
eyes on the carton
no the eggshell oh the eggshells i don't
know but that's that's that's that's
that's that's that's that's that's
that's that's that's i don't trust that
i don't know but it says it's like a
huge source of chaos because patty patty
somehow now hasn't that philly just
kills him
patty somehow now
has an in on somebody with chickens i
don't know what is this bro doing that i
don't know but she has started to sh
organic eggs have started to show up in
the house that she's getting we ain't
got a chicken no we ain't got a chicken
and she writes on it the date on the egg
no not on the egg who knows what she's
doing down there she writes on the card
crew balls she writes on the carton hey
we got these at this date i don't trust
that i don't trust it either that's why
i started inventory system i'm sorry i
love you back i want a [__] grocery
store stamp on the carton can't trust
those either though i know those
establishments get real wonky with uh
you know the dates i've seen the 60
minutes
expose that's why you go in the back for
the milk go all the way to the back that
don't matter yes it does
you get a fresh one and get you all the
time it's colder back there though uh
this this eggshell dog thing i don't
know about this that's dumb you can
technically anything that starts
technically i don't know about it they
give you rice and hamburger meat when
they when they got diarrhea you can
technically feed your dog eggshells but
only if your veterinarian thinks it's a
good idea that's not what i saw
contain countries gotta find a vet to
play ball
yeah uh which some dogs need supplement
in their diets however there are easier
ways to give your dog more calcium and
eggshells aren't the tastiest option
yeah they're nuts how about that [__]
milk bones [__] oh yeah
eggshells can be an excellent source of
calcium and protein for your dog and
they will they will support strong bones
and healthy teeth yeah who wrote that
egg.com
a dog wrote that
that was signed patches
i also didn't steal your slipper
[Laughter]
so what he had taken
what do you mean was there there was
there was there more to that no it's
just now i can't do it that's egregious
i can't leave open cracked eggshells
just out in the open air of the fridge i
was sealing them up and hiding them
that's how smart people deal with morons
what they take it away from you i know
yeah did i do to you yeah no [__] um
yeah no so i'm kind of screwed i'm a
little upset i didn't get to have my
eggies this morning because i was in
such a bad mood
i was [__] pissed and she set me up
real real [__] cute too i was in the
kitchen i wasn't eating i didn't she was
making my own she's like hey can you
hand me an egg i'm like well you're in
the kitchen you just kidding she got
busy i walked she's got to train you
should you rub your face in the
eggshells
i got scritches afterwards
i was on my knees have my neck up get
over here let me rub that belly yeah so
i'm pissed man that's how i that's how
i've done it since i moved out of my
[__] house you know in college well
this is how i'd handle it at the foley
house 15 years or something you're not
going to do it this way what you just do
it anyway
no let them know whose boss that's just
throw them in there that's outrageous
well you're it does look cool better too
it looks i guarantee you you do that a
couple of times at a cardinal show right
back up i also don't know how
right this is the perfect setting for
something like this that takes that
extra step of work
she just bought it two days ago she came
home filled it up it looks great but in
the hustle and bustle of a day-to-day
life yeah i don't know if she's gonna
get tickets mountain up like in the
middle of the [__] lunch shift i
don't know she's gonna [__] yeah
place those in there at all times yeah
try doing that when you're in the weeds
on a western omelet i know you know what
i mean trying to get them hot and hot
and fresh out there to the [__] crowd
yeah i got a question for the gentleman
from pennsylvania
t-bone uh so this is the thing in the
south you know every mom i feel like has
stuff in the kitchen that's too specific
and just sort of jams up the works did
you guys have the deviled egg tray
in your homes what no wait maybe in like
the like in the one part of the
uh kitchen where like all the [__] is as
far as like the cat i don't even know
what that is the casserole dishes and
stuff like that you weren't that wasn't
out on a daily basis was it no it would
just be jamming up a cabinet somewhere
oh yeah yeah yeah of course sure the
deviled egg tray is
oh that thing no we didn't have that it
looks like it looks like like a painting
thing yeah yeah no no how many double
eggs were you eating down there
none that's why i was jamming out the
works so
this is what this kid's trying to
[__] tell walking around in a
seersucker suit eating deviled eggs
every day nah you know what i thought i
do declare
in chicago
uh
one thing i did [__] hate that would
jam up the [__] we had like i said we
had a lazy susan still does still down
there still spinning around um the
lasers using in the cabinet like in the
corner cabinet sure at the bottom what
would always [__] jam me up real hard
the blender was in there nah yeah now
it's not gonna be falling apart mainly
top we the blender stayed out i think
really a lot of counter space out there
the blender stayed out yeah
whoa uh-huh
big margarita family
i don't know what to tell you baby niecy
booms parties rod likes a mudslide huh
holy [__] jesus the blender out that's
wild maybe i couldn't
that's crazy no no i'm correcting myself
it was under it was in a different
cabinet under yeah yeah i'm correcting
myself it for sure didn't stay out it
was under something um
but uh
that [__] uh
lettuce dryer did you have that put you
out of your [__] mind that plastic
thing a paper towel yeah
we had that no [__] way
i would have had my gi joes in there
doing a gravitron
skeleton three tickets skeletons
skeletors all smoked up into graviton
gee hi joe's dj
in the middle
get the [__] out
another thing that thing jammed up every
[__] drawer that was in i remember
just [__] that thing was nice
and it's fun yeah
yeah man that's what everybody got i
don't know if you might be too young to
remember this there was a moment in the
90s where everybody freaked out about
how clean their their vegetables were
they're gonna you get the salmonella and
the stuff on there and they're recalling
[__] spinach and all that stuff i
didn't start eating vegetables till
about 2014. it was wild it was so wild
that they came out with this product
that people use for a long time that you
sprayed on your uh fruit and then washed
it it was like soap for your fruit and
vegetables
that's still that's still what's it
called
uh vegetable wash or something something
like that yeah i mean
i just said vegetables yeah yeah yeah
that's it something along those lines no
i had a cool name like a furloni or
something like that
lawn spray or something that doesn't
sound like non-chemically that doesn't
sound like you want to clean your
vegetables with freelancers well it was
something and it came right it came out
kill those goddamn bugs it came out that
that wasn't that good for you the wash
sure isn't good for you t-bone you got
anything
buddy i got nothing huh i got some veg i
got some arm and hammer vegetable wash
yeah we do that we got some stuff really
yeah yeah yeah she likes to go like uh
anti-chemical sometimes
those europeans are all natural oh yeah
know what they're doing okay let's talk
about mint mobile oh mint mobile bit
mobile met mobile let's talk about mint
mobile and i want you to hear me loud
and clear uh-huh cause that's the way
you're gonna hear it on min mobile and
you know what else you're not getting
jacked by some long-term contract you're
not getting a bunch of hidden fees 15
beans a month 15 bucks out the door and
let me tell you who's got the stamp of
approval on that who's that patty
patty's all over
there's got to be a catch it's too good
to be true it ain't patty it's not i'm
telling you that right now switched over
what's the catch uh there is none
uh mint mobile secret sauces they were
the first company sell wireless service
online only they cut out the cost of
retail stores they're not paying rent on
every goddamn corner in new york city
philadelphia chicago los angeles there
you go no they cut out all the research
retail stores pass those sweet savings
directly on to you 15 bucks 15 bucks for
anyone who hates their phone bill mint
mobile offers premium wireless for just
15 clams a month look at it uh gives you
the best rate whether you're buying one
or for a family and mint family started
just two lines new age family that's
what
yeah use your own phone with any mint
mobile plan and keep the same number
along with all your existing contacts
switch them in mobile get premium
wireless start at just 15 bucks listen
to get this plan for just 15 bucks a
month and get the plan shipped directly
to your door for free go to mint
mobile.com garbage that's mint mobile
dot com garbage call your wireless bill
to 15 bucks a month at mintmobile.com
back to that show there back to the show
all right let's get into some [__]
questions over here what do you say i
think we should do some cues here gang
as you know when you sign up for the old
patreon there you get a question read on
the air yes
we receive a lot of submissions but this
is just the best way to do it those
patreons get a first crack at yes they
do shout out to the homies um all right
this one's from ryan how trash is it to
have two roommates and those roommates
are marrying each other
that's bad he said also yanni p called
you guys the wawa twins and i'm here for
it shout out to [__] shout out to
yanny b i like it
um
ever live with a couple no we you're
gonna hate me for this and i already do
uh when my when my lady was moving here
and we got that apartment that i first
had
up in the heights the first apartment
with our friend no no no the one i went
out on my own and got when she was
coming for like six months at a time you
did oh yeah you used to airbnb that
joint yeah yeah yeah
well when we were looking for that my
wife like she was like let's
find something like a room even
and i was like you're [__] no way am
i living with
am i being a couple with a [__]
some strange weirdo guy or girl i'm like
no [__] way yeah
that's wild yeah that's that was like a
no [__] no way would i ever want to
do that now looking at an apartment with
that it's a couple and you are like well
a lot of not a lot of comics did that
when they moved to new york for the
first time they were living with like a
couple or like a married couple that had
a room and they would rent that room
i'll take a stranger
straight up uh-huh i'd rather strangers
straight up [__] that dude yeah not with
your lady
that's no bueno no can't do that
um all right this one's from mike
crawford 10 homie first question is it
garbage to mix two different types of
pasta i made shells and angel hair and
it blew my hair back
i've done it for sure it's a good time
it makes you feel a little fancy even
though it's real trash shells and angel
hairs in it you at least gotta go like
same shape-esque yeah linguine and
[__] spaghetti something yeah shells
and rigatoni you can't go [__] you
can't go long in shorts together that's
[__] crazy
that's weird man no you can't be doing
that although i've done that so many
[__] times so many times you know
what drives me crazy i'll run into this
every once in a while at the house not
so much now because i'm kind of off the
path there
when they don't make the whole [__]
thing i just made a half of that but i
put the whole box in there what are we
doing i don't think you're supposed to
make the whole box yes you are
one thing spaghetti and one thing is
sauce that's that's how it matches up
that's for that listen well then why is
the sauce have a resealable lid if
you're supposed to use the whole thing
because you have to put the water in
there to shake it up and then you could
reuse it for something like a glass for
milk then why would you need a lid
you're still not answering my question
what you're not a serving size is not a
box and jar of pasta sauce i think that
100 percent is i think that would be the
industry
of americans
i don't know why i said it like that
americans like pasta and i'm american
don't you think that maybe you're
no
i'm not giving you this don't you think
maybe your take on serving size is a
little skewed
to the heavier i'm not saying you eat
the whole thing you then you have
leftovers you're telling me you don't
make a whole box of pasta when you make
pasta no half get the [__] out what are
we doing we're just gonna lie it's all
we're gonna do we're gonna lie to each
other here that's what he'll might be
friends i don't know what you want from
me toby help me out i'm making it with
my wife
yeah okay you're making another way to
make the box of pasta there you go toby
depends
what i don't think that a jar of sauce
is enough for a whole box of pasta most
times
that's how much that might be correct
yeah you're nuts
and
first of all
relax it's pasta okay you're about to
[__] come across the table
easy does it big fat i don't know why
it's a resealable uh jar but it is but i
also know you never [__] use half a
jar of spaghetti sauce then put the lid
back on put it back in the refrigerator
and then use it at a later date that's
[__] disgusting you for sure can do
that no dude that gets all nasty no it
does it's got an airtight scene that's
crazy nobody does that though i'm
telling i guarantee you people do that
you've never done that you've never not
once in your life you've ever resealed a
jar of spaghetti no i find that i
[__] cook it all i cook it all i cook
the whole jar i put the water in there i
put it in there i cook the whole jar
also too those little things are tomato
paste
you use those if you don't use all that
you throw that out you don't [__]
wrap that up in tin foil and put it back
in the refrigerator
you know like the actual tomato paste
that you're supposed to add the tomato
sauce like out of a jar it's in like it
comes in like a can a lot yeah it's like
real thick sure you know what i mean you
understand what i'm talking about yeah
if you're making a sauce from scratch
with like some [__] some crushes yeah
that's different than a
yeah that's
to me that's a different type of
ingredient than a jar of your i agree
i'm just saying i don't think anybody
that's like you don't reuse that either
i don't think anybody's there it's not
the same thing okay and a resealable jar
of pasta sauce
it's resealable yeah i'm not saying it's
not
so is the orange juice what
damn yeah exactly thank you but you know
but everybody you don't [__] save it
you make the whole thing jesus christ
you make the whole jar of sauce don't
you toby
sometimes yeah sometimes damn i'm not
saying it's insane to not do it but
you're acting like never like it's a
it's an act of war if somebody reseals
uses half a jar of pasta sauce well
because then the problem is then you go
into the [__] the th you think you
have pasta i mean let's let's define
problem i don't think this is a huge
problem whatever you're about to explain
but continue
you think you have enough pasta and then
oh [__] there's only a quarter box of
[__] fettuccine left well the next
thing you know you're going to the
shells well who leaves a quarterback
that's insane a half but you're not
measuring out a half a box perfectly
i think i'm right on this ah you use the
whole box of pasta and the whole in the
house i'm making a single if i'm making
dinner for myself it's a half a box
halfway you're gonna put the leftovers
in there anyway that you can heat it up
then i have to eat pasta tomorrow yeah
of course that's what you do when you
make pasta you make it for a couple of
days i think that's what you do not
everybody does that i think everybody
the italians got to be freaking out
watching this
there's no italians watch this
is it dirty dirty
shout out to vinnie boombox
[Laughter]
i see what you're saying but yeah i
don't know i've also
i mean we've argued a lot of things this
is
your your feet are quite dug in on this
that i mean that's insane to me sure the
whole thing's insane
you not backing me up that's sucking you
up
betrayed [__] anybody that'll hear me
at this point you make a whole you make
you buy one box of pasta you buy one box
of [__] you buy one jar of sauce whether
it's francesco ronaldi prego that seems
like [__] whatever you want to use
you want to use [__] rails you got a
little bit of money you do that
you make it
you make it all you heat it all up
what you don't eat you put in a tub i
don't believe that you're going to make
a whole box of pasta and not eat it also
and one in one second i can't do that i
can't do that i can't sit here and i
can't i can't eat a whole thing i can't
eat a whole box of mazda
i can make anybody does anybody believe
that come on i'm not sitting there
eating a [__] whole thing of
pasta out of the eating 12 chili dogs in
one day
all right that's different
how pasta hits you a little bit harder
what
maybe if i had a big game the next day
had a carbo load
all right all right we're moving on we
have to agree to disagree on this one
because i can feel it slowly descending
into foleyville where it's not fun
not one jar of sauce and a fridge and
foliage jesus christ
um
this all this isn't all right this oh
jesus christ we're in pasta town right
now this ain't good
we're rolling out
let's go oh my god this is gonna be the
end of the podcast next stop manicotti
uh this is from erin 10 homie here never
had a question asked is it garbage to
not cook pasta sauce because the pasta
will heat it up when you pour it from
the jar into fresh pasta
i will do that one thousand percent okay
i think that's all i ever do that's real
trashy yeah welcome to my podcast are
you garbage
yeah of course it's real trashy in a
pinch it's different pan different pie
the first time that i discovered you
could just do that was like oh [__] i
want to go this far i didn't know you
were supposed to heat it up i thought
you just dumped it in there
until like later like way too late like
as of recently your mom wasn't heating
up the sauce i said a thousand times i
didn't pay attention what that broad was
doing i was eating garlic bread
somewhere waiting for my [__] sketti
to be cooked
i was having i was doing apps i never
paid attention to what she did i never i
don't know anything about cooking but
like just the whole
ambiance of
the sauce cooking slow on the stove okay
once the butter then you have the
boiling water
then when you're ready to [__] pull
the trigger okay the meatballs are done
the whatever's done you throw the you
throw the on the water let me pop a hole
in this bubble you didn't grow up with a
simmering uh thing of sauce on the on
the stovetop when she yeah well i'm sure
when she was doing that again i wasn't
paying attention let's go to now right
or as of the past 10 years when you're
making pasta it's typically probably for
yourself
sure right you're not doing the uh let
me simmer the sauce for 45 hours we do
i'm not i'm saying if you're making it
for yourself you're not doing i i heat
the sauce up yeah
for how long eating up and letting it i
mean us hold on the pain the pain the
picture you just painted was like
the the romanticizing
letting that simmer for a long time no
i'm not [__] grandma noosebomb that's
what i'm saying so if i'm making i
always just picture making it in my head
for myself
i'm not [__] simmering the sauce for
an hour you you i'll just dump it in the
[__] noodles whip it around and
[__] eat it out of the pot
that i don't wash the outside of because
that's how i get down now if you didn't
finish is that pot going in the fridge
whole
no i'm i'm i'm going to make half the
bot and i'm going to finish it okay with
half the box
what did you the whole thing of
spaghetti getting thrown right back in
the fridge oh yeah crack that lid make
sure the [__] cold air gets to it
that's the treacherous
so far is removing a shelf
i'll rearrange the shell so
you go in and someone's shelf is like
leaned up against the side of the fridge
i got a keg in there or something big
pot of num num in there
take that thing right out throw right on
the [__] heat
a little bit of water keep it moving
yeah i [__] yeah i never
i'm not transferring it from the pot to
another [__] thing then putting that
in there and then leaving that in there
now you go you keep it in the pot when i
cook something i mean i literally eat
till the point of it hurting i'll eat
all of it it sounds healthy yeah well
you know i got some issues too
doctor drew colby she started eating my
eggs uh no yeah i eat them uh i'll eat
everything and then if it's like a
little i'll probably
i'll leave it yeah so you're not heating
the sauce up i'm not heating the sauce
up and i'm going to listen without
reheating pasta that's to me i go i
guess this is the way i look at it i'm
not going to reheat pasta i'll just make
it make half the box eat that and then
in two days if i won't pass it again
i'll just make it all right let me fresh
let me i'm a gentleman
say it again i'm a gentleman no before
that what fresh pasta you'll do fresh
pasta i'm saying i'm not going to eat
reheated pasta i'm not going to
reheat it i understand i'm just saying i
don't i'm not going to make leftovers
i'm going to slice it up into little
pieces too i'm not gonna have leftovers
i'm just gonna make it again all right
okay
let me ask you this buddy i'm here for
it you're gonna make the pasta you're
not gonna heat up the sauce but
is the sauce room temperature you went
to the store and got it you didn't put
it in the fridge right yeah it's room
temp okay all right okay okay
all right did you just say that you cut
your spaghetti with a knife and a fork i
do i like it like that like a toddler
i've mentioned this multiple times on
the podcast he has to do the airplane to
eat it
rope it up unless they're on strike then
they go the railroad
choo choo
oh no the pinkerton
here comes the sketti train all aboard
my aunt mary catherine shout out to her
would uh make sure very irish would make
pasta really sounds polished
would make pasta and then in in the in
the uh cast iron skillet would add the
[__] sauce and cut it up dude it
makes it so [__] creamy and so good
with the meat sauce good nate
blow your compression socks right off
[__] really good
yeah that's how that's why i prefer it
now i'm [__] slow i wouldn't do it at
a restaurant
we were like john excuse me can you have
the chef chop this everybody
i wonder how that mary cat used to be
chat about my sketti but dude she would
do it so [__] good it was awesome
but i've mentioned that before sure here
on this broadcast
uh
this is from trounder and she used the
whole [__] jar of sauce like a lady
yo she's making it i guess i guess yeah
she wasn't making it for about eight
people yeah that's what i'm saying yeah
i think when i guess the whole misstep
in this is i also ultimately thought the
only time i'm making pasta
is i mean you would make it for myself
when i was you know either single or
whatever so
a whole box and a whole jar seemed
overkill i always thought that's how you
did it and you dealt with we dealt with
the rest of it i know we just we just
had a 12-minute discussion i understand
that's how you thought i was correcting
but i think where we got off on uh
off on uh
off on the wrong foot one would say
uh this is from tround round is it
trashy to wear jeans with flip-flops
i don't think so
i think it's tough now it was kind of in
fashion a few years ago you got to make
a little money to do that
right it depends
down the shore it's all right you get a
nice pair of rainbows set of jeans maybe
a cuff on them you're going out to like
a little bit nicer of a dinner or
something sure where it's like you're
not in your [__] body you can't pull
it off no you got to be in shape you got
to be in shape you got to be in shape
got to be in shape uh yeah fat guy in
flip-flops just looks like you can't tie
your shoes yeah yeah it looks like
you're late for a final or something
like that that's a tough look you gotta
be in shape you gotta you gotta have a
little bit of a couple of bucks too yeah
tommy pope could wear she could wear you
know
jeans
and he a dreamboat he dresses like a
[__] fox too
does the whole season summer fall winter
wears real nice stuff yeah right now
he's rocking a lot of uh linen yeah
hot guys do that you know
not me that's why i'm changing to a
linen shirt after this before i leave
shout out to fellow hot guys out there
uh this one's from jono is it garbage to
wish you had an uncle mike like kippy
until you realize your uncle pickles
government name is
michael was a [__] riddle wrapped in
a [__] whatever holy [__] shout out
to uncle pics uncle picky had to be all
right what is he into he'll buy you sake
he was buying your booze when you were
11.
he can have one
we started talking about we were talking
about that uh this this
uh yesterday okay uh who gave you your
first sip of beer
my dad your dad
the neighbor
never got me all [__] up no yeah my
dad okay yeah uh
that was big let me get a sip yeah yeah
yeah i remember specifically
it was after a [__] softball game
they were they had a keg they were all
[__] hanging out kids are running
around
it's the 80s you're doing cake stands
just
get your shirt off get up there this is
when we used to just play in cars kids
don't really do that now we would just
play in a parked car
just [__] climbing over everything
pretending to be driving someone out or
something yeah it's like we were a
family going on vacation all kinds of
[__] a lot of role-playing
but it was one of these parties they
were like still sweaty they were like
[__] men [__] ice-cold jenny cream
ale so i remember exactly what kind of
beer it was was it a plastic cup he's
like dang it
yeah i still taste it i pay for that in
a couple of years oh yeah i can still
taste it
from back in the day
uh i remember it was a new year's eve we
were up the mountains shout out to
lakewool and paul pack up there and love
white ball back
just sound like you were doing baby talk
i will wake home ball whack i love lake
woah and ball back uh shout out to it uh
we got up there skiing she's got a
halfway decent potato pancake up there
okay yeah just anywhere just go and
just
i mean okay say that ten times fast lake
won a palm pack banana potato pancake
wall and paul pack potato pancake
that's the name of your dad's softball
team
two off two down the potato pancakes
look good this year
oh here come the lobkies
[Laughter]
seems to be an eight-year-old in the
outfield drunk he looks like
yeah they lost to the blintzes last week
i got to face the pierogies in the world
series there we go we got one more i
think that's all of them
[Laughter]
that's all the eastern european potato
dishes
the hashbrowns didn't make it out of the
round robin
pretty good
i was gonna say the tortellini is the
italian theme
okay we'll go with
hashbrowns hey there's no wrong answers
in spitballing
[__] [__] um
what the [__]
oh potato pancakes
your dad giving you alcohol yeah no we
went to a volleyball pack the potato
pancakes capital of the world
they have a large eastern european uh
population up there good potato pancakes
i think you just said population too
population
have good pierogies too um
what
dad drinking yeah but the latest new
year's eve
i was i don't know how old
my brother and cousins were a little
older than me
maybe
they were teens so i might have been i
don't know 11 12 something like that
either way you were annoying i could
think of that
shot skid marks on my own
skid marks in this undies eating this
[__] buddy noodies
they're out hunting for deer
you're in there playing duck hunt and
eating [__]
shells yeah i mean
i was a child um
but they all gave us uh they gave us
like a small taste of champagne for new
year's all right and uh i remember not
being a fan so i asked for a beer
instead i like took a sip and i'm like
nah this thing for me let me get one of
those [__] cl's that [__] joe's
slurping down over there i was like hey
this isn't a bar you don't get to choose
like we were being nice enough and like
you know letting you celebrate you know
hey keep the bellini this is a that's a
little stale yeah you got something
fresh
man when i was a kid i preferred the
martinelli stuff
the sparkly sparkling cider or whatever
yeah [__] champagne give me the [__]
good that was big guy somebody won a
tournament i don't know if it was i
vaguely remember i don't know if it was
a team i was on or my brother a cousin
or something
i forget what it was i would guess no
yeah
and uh
chess club and they like celebrated was
it the garlic non championships
i came in third that year
which i never [__] with a garlic not
until much later in life they're a
little overrated not if you get a good
one
yeah but that's the problem yeah sure
it's tough to get a good sure so i would
say as a holder over right and you can't
do knots and pizza because it's like
just get the pizza or just get the knots
that was my that was my
that's how i got around that's how i
that's how i was able to stay fat when
we were really really poor not a thing i
was able to stay fat in the west village
because you could instead of getting a
couple slices at uh forensics what was
it
furies next doors
instead of getting their [__] slices
which are like uh three four hours you
get a [__] order of garlic nuts and
some sauce for like a buck 50.
go heavy with the parm cheese i'm aware
i was there baby not bad um
yeah but oh they were they like popped
martin i remember and i remember being
like what the [__] i thought it was
booze i guess i was really young i don't
know
that [__] was hard we had like a we were
like a big
but that's like even weird to me now to
be like
11 year olds popping
champagne
i think we all we wanted to drink as
like eight-year-olds yeah that's how it
was [__] set up it was like yeah
[__] can i have a ship here you can
have a thing or whatever just wait you
know when you show up at that
thanksgiving and you have a [__]
champagne flute sitting in front of you
and they're going around [__]
knocking everybody off with [__]
martinelli's yeah you're [__]
chipping the lights fantastic yeah
good times yeah
this one's real trashy this is from
wilson have you ever finished your dates
drink when you stand up to leave a
restaurant [__] yeah that's real [__]
exclusively
all the time
let's go yeah i'm not down in there come
on
all right will you finish it for me i'm
scared
yeah it's real real [__] trashy love
that
big fan i'm typically
my wife doesn't booze that much anymore
she'll do one so typically she'll order
when we first sit so i'll have it
throughout at this point but back in the
day it was like i'll give me that i'll
[__] skull it steal the glass too put
it in your purse hoods we're walking
with this
love stealing the glass i remember the
one time she was like we got back she's
like oh i stole this for you i was like
i'm going to marry you he [__] stole
the because i was like oh this glass is
sweet it was like a goose island glass
or something [__] stella glass
[__] dirt bag man you go down to my
mom's house down there in wildwood
china cabinet
it's like keenan's in the kitchen baby
[__]
this [__]
stellar stemware ever that's like fancy
big thing of peanut oil that's like if
you have guests coming like get my uncle
mike uncle pack give them a stellar
glass let them know i don't feel fancy
yeah we're thieves i think i broke a lot
of them in the dishwasher though when i
was quarantining down there
shout out to the stella glass that blew
us away uh-huh i don't even know where
you get those you gotta you gotta order
a keg
no we've never ordered a keg of stella i
can't guarantee you that you stole them
from restaurants yes exactly how the
restaurant gets is if you start selling
if you start if you start selling yeah
they want it branded in the glass yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
good milk glass though uh this one's for
michael first time long time someone
breaks out cocktail alcohol infused
popsicles for me that's trash what are
your thoughts um that and the jello
shots
they're different the jello shot and a
popsicle or jell-o shots or
child trash that's crazy
to put them in the scene are you saying
they're doing those did become popular
for a minute a few summers ago they were
champagne pops i think yeah i mean you
could like make them and stuff like i
don't think people are really selling
like a nice party yeah it's like a july
fourth party you're on a boat or a yeah
get the [__] out of here with that i
think i think i i told you i don't know
it was on air when we were i was 16.
someone got their hands on like
a five gallon
bucket of water ice like you know like
the ones you would see in like rita's
like in the cooler yeah and we were on a
dock at
some party on like boat parade or
something real trashy we're all dressed
up in [__] red white and blue
everybody's [__] plotzed and this guy
this guy breaks out a five gallon bucket
of [__] blue water rice
and just starts dumping vodka in it and
like just ship and dude everybody's just
sitting there getting [__] ossified
i had about three quarts of that [__] i
was [__] the house
trying to score with chicks in the
[__] bar yeah you can [__] blue
raspberry all over your face oh yeah
it's a tough look but i get it it's fun
in the right now it's a purple tongue
thinks you're hot yeah in the right
moment it's okay
but that's a you know
that's trashy yeah how do you feel about
this i'm listening this is on the on the
the home entertaining front
go to a [__] party and someone's
whipped up a batch of sangria
you fly with that that's not my i think
i might have had it once or twice in my
life it's not for me
that kind of [__] i don't nice glass
pitcher sangria was never for me i don't
like give me a [__] coors light yeah
any of that [__] just give me a [__]
give me a a a cooler a [__] dog we
were we were drinking [__]
freezing cold bud lights out of an ice
cold cooler that's the best a cold
cooler a fridge but that's not gonna fly
with the [__] with you know when
that's not when people wanna do like a
nice spread when they wanna put a nice
glass thing of sangria with the chopped
up fruit or the [__] alcohol pops
that's that's well they can that's
pottery barn [__] they can do they can
have their sangria i'm gonna have a beer
all right
yeah that's i mean i don't know what
party or event you're going to where
someone doesn't have beers even if it's
a classy one you're drinking stella out
of a stolen glass sure
you know sure i'm not saying they don't
have that i'm just asking if you partake
in any of that no i don't like any
that's what i'm saying i don't like any
of that [__] you did the punch in
college right when you'd make the the
[__]
no
really in high school we did that we
would make that
big on that in college no keg's in
college okay get a keg of lions head or
natty light for about you know a couple
nitrous tanks you like those cherry
swizzles or whatever down at the shore
the tully nuts shout out to the number
one tavern couple cherry swizzlers who
are you my pop-ups
how much they charging you for a cherry
swizzler nowadays sounds like an old guy
with real handsy uh yeah any that's
different that's a fun event drinkie can
only get in that kind of place also if
somebody uh a homie hit me up was like
hey what's the name of that bar you guys
were talking i told him like it's a real
hole in the wall he sent me pictures of
bean and he's like this place sucks but
it's great yeah it's all right the
[__] best bar baby ice cold ac
cooking in there what's the name of that
joint shout out to the number one tavern
down there number one tavern down there
at wildwood north wildwood new jersey
check it out want to be down there this
week no big deal yeah you going down to
shore i will talk about it over there
somewhere else on another program we do
um
this is from matt 10 homie never had one
red is it garbage you keep a completely
dead plant in your house in hopes that
you can still bring it back to life
i
love that um
yeah i have there's this big one that we
have this big one and when my wife was
in germany for a little while it was on
me to [__] went back to visit the fam
for like two months or whatever it was
on me to [__] keep our keeper alive
i'm big on that i got a money tree going
my money tree is cooking that thing's
like my kid
i see those the leaves dangling a little
bit
load her up uh i'm big on that it's like
uh
i talk to them too i go grow my babies
you're supposed to talk to plants i
don't like you little [__] [__] you
better start [__] growing yeah start
flexing on them
um
yeah that's big
it's tough
people say plants are like easy peasy
but like you forget it the problem is if
you forget one day it's easy to forget
nine days in a row yeah once you get out
of the cycle it's real tough to stay on
top of it it really is i got a cactus or
something i can't tell if it's growing
or dying
it won't stand up straight
it keeps like trying to crawl out of the
pot i'm telling you it's weird
it's a crab dude
hey yeah you got a ferret
because i i'm pretty sure it's a
porcupine you put in a pot
i put a stick in there to try to get it
to grate me
it's growing towards the light you find
it in the trash no that's the thing it's
growing it's true yeah it's going to try
to kill itself
it's going away from the light
jesus christ just take me it's weird
i'll set it up and i'll [__] put it
somewhere and when i come back in the
next day it's laying on its side it's
trying to like climb out of the thing
it's weird man yeah and maybe this
doesn't like a lot of light
but it's a desert
plant no i don't know if it's a cactus
it's uh not a cactus i don't think i
don't think it's a plant it doesn't oh
no a succulent that's what it is yeah
it's a cactus though is that a catalyst
so yeah yeah yeah
it's i mean in the world of a cacti and
it's uh
they're supposed to they live in like
very like low water whatevers oh maybe
i'm low moisture
yeah you shouldn't be [__] water oh
water hydroponics i do it every day oh
you shouldn't water that every day
really yeah he's trying to get away from
the water god damn it
no
money trees you shouldn't use sierra
mist too
what do you got on succulent uh they're
similar they're part of the same like
cousins basically
cacti cousins
kissing cousins what was that by the way
kissing cousins talk about that hotel
new hampshire that was a movie i think
it was just straight interesting
i don't know seems like real hillbilly
[__] if you ask me um there was a movie
with rob lowe and uh michelle pfeiffer i
think all right this one is from eric uh
is it garbage to put a big purchase on
your credit card because of a positive
conversation you had with a personal
injury attorney
[Laughter]
i respect this dude going for broke baby
that's real dirtbag you get some
positive news that's a very important
thing oh yeah he said i'm gonna make
seven million dollars i think we did
this not that long ago what well we were
talking about something i was like oh
cool i don't have to worry about paying
that that that
something yeah
no not my schmaxes
my schmaxes are all taken care of um
yeah that's real dirt i like it though i
like it i've i you know i've been
fortunate enough this is you know jesus
christ now i feel like you a little bit
um
also yeah this guy's really got you
knocking i just got him knocking we
should get a personal injury lawyer on
the patreon that's pretty good
that's good and i also had an oh [__] i
had another really good idea oh we
should get a juggalo too yes okay that's
pretty good a juggalo a personal injury
attorney
uh
also flying next to i mean we'll talk
about it more on our phase but flying
next to this [__] lunatic i mean dude
he blesses himself way too often on a
plane to make me feel like we're going
down this dude's over there doing
[__] the sign of the cross every
tuesday
holy [__] makes you think jesus is in
the bathroom what the [__] dude i'm
laying that cloth over me i got the
bible out it's [__] kevorka over here
if i can sit next to the corinthians
excuse me
i'm like having fun i'm listening to a
[__] you bless yourself when you you
bless yourself and say an act that can
act a contrition when you take off yeah
well do it [__] privately next so you
can slide into heaven when you you had
everybody in rows seven through ten
freaked the [__] out
you're eating the cheese at the body of
christ
with the vodka blood of the lord
speaking in tongues
i'm giving her communion to the dirt
balls in the back
he's got a bottle of hooch on them huh
boys
you don't want to burn in hell do you
start drinking
[Laughter]
ah that's tough man
all right uh
let's see here this one
is from
chris uh 20 homies shout out to the 20
shareholder is a garbage have a fish
tank and a bird cage in the same room
i don't think
i have to answer that that that's two of
the worst i would assume smelling pets
together fish tank if it's not done
right is bad yeah bird cage
that kids just don't use unless you get
like a cockatoo or something big in
there if this is like a parakeet they
don't smell i don't know hey clean that
[__] out yeah but i'm saying yeah that's
another thing it's like you got to stay
on top of it these things are rarely
stayed on top of i'm not big on on on
the laziness takes over i'm not big on
the keeping of the birds
although i love birds why what do they
do i don't understand it they're
beautiful what do you mean i love a bird
but i don't feel right keeping it in the
cage
gotta let them out there do their thing
yeah but i don't think those birds
yeah they would they would fly around
i don't know if they would survive in
the climate those like [__] yes luke
and sam's are going to last in a new
york winter daddy oh maybe [__] the
pigeons are going to jack him up dude
sweet get him a rent control department
yeah that's not going to make it on his
own
yeah no [__] i [__] don't
i'm not saying release them i'm saying
you shouldn't even bring those kind of
birds into that all right but this is
another thing they're in there like
they're at the pet shop you know what i
mean it's not like i'm going to jamaican
bringing them back with me from sandals
like i'm buying them at a pet shop in
new york hey if anybody asks you on the
plane
you're from jersey you're my scene eye
dog
here put these glasses on and
he act
talk ah man i wish i had a bird i could
talk it's pretty good
um
i have an rd garbage question i'm
listening are you garbage if you go to
get water for the crew you get yourself
a giant one and kippy a tiny one that's
crazy you've had it out for me since
this [__] podcast started no [__]
i have to drink a lot of water tonight
it's just not a power move
i oh dude he's got a gallon of water
on his [__] and i he goes up he texts
he texts the girl i'll get walters i'll
get whatever you need he buys two rinky
dink little [__] fiji the fiji's dick
what are you talking about that's classy
yeah but you're not supposed to drink
that much of that you got a gallon of it
i'm looking out for you kippy
you stink
i was legit man i open up the fridge i
go where the [__] are the water your
dirt ball digestive system is not
accustomed to a fine product like fiji
you drink pure life a like a scumbag
yeah but a big one at least this is like
let me get a thimble of fiji this is
this is fuji anyway hold on
where'd you get this the guy on the
corner it's lauren hill's new water
here's something else let's talk about
one way oh what else all right hold on
that's what's even happening i had i had
i had lunch i got a lot of horrible we
spent we spent four days in l.a i got a
lot of hard feelings i had lunch before
this so i got a big bottle of water you
have a diet coke in the fridge and i got
him first well i died coke you pulled it
out of the ocean it was all wet and
stuff i'm not touching that thing what
do you mean it was soaked what that
that's been in there i didn't buy you a
new diet coke
why not because there was one in there
you just said i got you that you got a
diet coke i said you had it this is real
fishy no one time because i'm gonna go
you the whole thing's [__] up you had
a diet coke in there i knew there was no
red bull in there i got toby or red
blood i got you i got you two ounces of
water
you [__] this guy's one way
name streets after you
[Laughter]
this is
uh guys you gotta wrap it up we love
yous we do gang we absolutely love you
come out and see us on the old live show
there things are about to kick into high
gear so come out and see us we love you
we'll see you next week peace